[Musik]
auf jeden fall von mir gewohnt von mir
kommen immer wertvolle sachen die auf
dem rhein für möglich halte die jungs
weise erscheint überraschen ich will
nicht durch standard content bringen
okay ich bin ganz ehrlich ich bin sehr
lange überlegt ob ich dieses video weg
machen wird natürlich werden meine deine
unsere privatsphäre ein arbeit finde
youtube ist natürlich von einheit von
mir und verloren
und deswegen natürlich jetzt auch eine
freundin bei der allerersten freiheit
ein großteil genau einen grund natürlich
ist auch meine freunde ein großer teil
davon und dafür darf natürlich nicht
fehlen
ich rufe dir einfach durch verantworten
immer wieder drehen
meine freundin natürlich nicht fehlen
und wir haben ja auch immer gesagt du
musst ganz für den erfolg nicht ganz
kurz und erstmalig am stück auf jeden
fall hat im titel der wahrscheinlich
auch schon gewesen wir haben ja es ist
natürlich für viele interessenten
schöpferisch meint ich bin mir zwar
nicht alle details und wir haben zu
wenig pause aber wie wollen sie da rein
vorrang
auf jeden fall das gute an der medien
aber die ansetzung immer wenn wir an
dass sie denken kommt sofort hin
[Musik]
überhaupt erst wieder
und das lohnt
[Musik]
das war natürlich linien das bitte gern
und mit ihm verlieren dabei dem nicht
studieren ist nun mit dem überwintern
aber da und natürlich auch bei dem
instagram traum von der vom spieler die
einstellung von mexiko ich bin auf tour
ist ein lieber instyle
jedes kabel partner war alles vorbei und
schreibt einfach eine an das thema sein